ela vai eu vou
o futebol tem porquê pois nunca tive que
sair fizeram um filme sobre a história
do primeiro filme um tanto que eu não
posso contar uma história agora eu posso
contar histórias sobre ciência para quem
não gosta de ciência e história que vou
contar o recesso alguns cientistas da
universidade de oxford e inventaram
completos é científico nos destruir um
processo científico toda aquela coisa da
hipótese até da experimentação da
corrupção
usando uma tecnologia bastante inovadora
essa tecnologia estamos todos mãos em
2007 mostrou no chamado kerem shalom
anos que morava com um problema sobre é
teoria da formação e da evolução das
galáxias como todos sabemos
são conjuntos de estrelas baixo
substituição ao universo existem dois
tipos de lácteos como a nossa via láctea
respirar isso como certa a votação
também tem de falar que realmente
existem algumas formas
o pressuposto os astrônomos é que
galáxias espirais uma via láctea são
também ótimas bastante novas incubadoras
infantários estrelas nacional das
estrelas josé essas que emitem uma
responsa
está muito quente e ricas são notícias
velhas acabadas que emitem luz através
da eleição de maia para charles que
perceber como é que as novas respirar e
se desenvolvem para se tornar as velhas
colocou a transição que acontece mundo o
primeiro de forma e deixem de fumar às
trevas ou deixam filmar os dois
primeiros só depois mudou a sua entrega
para provar a sua teoria adquirida era
precisamente primeiro usavam de forma a
provar essa teoria eu tenho que fazer
uma coisa encontrar galáxias elípticas
com zonas azuis algo nunca visto para
encontrar essas galáxias não tenho uma
base de dados mais um milhão de imagens
de galáxias
o movimento ilustrado e maxwell estados
unidos chamadas o ano de jetons cais
erva e os astrônomos contém um total de
100 nomes galáxias usa um algoritmo que
permite que o trator o galaxy
esperamos através da cor é que nos pagar
taxas muito mais nas costas muitos no
algoritmo não há ainda desenvolver a
inteligência artificial que emitem os
pacotes através da sua geometria
shoppings que temos no momento não tinha
outra hipótese senão olhar as galáxias
uma a uma e foi o fez durante uma semana
ela cuidava olhava pra mais galáxias
almoçava olhar mais galáxias e dormir
provavelmente sonhava com mais galáctico
cerca de 50.000 encontrou o que estava
procurando assim por cento esta mostra
vai transformar com com jesus e por você
teoria isso é uma conclusão ainda mais
importante uma mulher muito legal de
fazer isto toda toda toda vez que eu
indo para concluir mas científico não
posso estar a dizer que seja uma nessa
altura uma das colegas quer deixar o
índice cac led
esta famosa prova que o problema é
semelhante à votação dos galaxy
ela também precisava de saber qual é a
instituição da cotação das galáxias nos
ou skype mas vamos com tudo pago uma
parte cerveja
as pessoas perguntam criar um caso com
seu tempo que o lugar de maxi pereira
mas foi já no primeiro é um cara melhor
você não é do site bastante simples
mostrava a imagem da galáxia pessoas 25
anos você acha que você acha que está
melhor
a espiral foi uma espiral invictos a
direção da proteção especial vão para o
site
cerca de 50 100 pessoas somente irão
participar os tronos melhores pessoas
com algum interesse na área
é mas que não ia passar diz chamar um
site legal é preciso que ela precisou
foi lançado há um ano de julho de 2007
um dia tiveram cerca de 60 mil
as ações da light mas no último minuto
já em novembro queda de ensino
catalogadas mais 40 vezes mora mas que
quer que tenha feito uma semana do final
das votações eram tantas que o carro de
som que eu tiver um substituto para
manter um site online
ao pontuar que era essas pessoas não
eram astrônomos amadores
elas nem sequer eram fanáticos ciência
tanto quando as pessoas percebiam que
costuma fazer e ajudar o processo
científico entrou em pânico e minavam em
60 vezes
desculpa não fazia ideia que isto vai
ser facto usada para a nossa pesquisa e
não sei que estou fazendo e se estava a
brincar que eu usei o que vocês estão a
ajudar o processo de fato estavam
estavam pensamento para contribuir para
ajudar e não tenho nada em troca e
estamos tecnicamente o ministério da
economia e econômico
motivados o fato dessas pessoas só
querem me ajudar elas não teriam
interesse particular em astronomia nos
pediram o golpe gates roupas 1 e ver se
o universo tem projetos fantásticos
um dos exemplos é chata ninguém mostra
imagens de animais no parque nacional do
serengeti na tanzânia
essas imagens são geradas por cerca de
225 câmeras distribuídas ao longo do
pacto são assinadas por que a loura em
movimento e tem um surfista no funk
tempo sem partido passou qualquer
espécie passa né na câmara
isso permitiu subir ao pódio as
montagens movimento que aceitam as
espécies que vivem na fotografia limitam
os biólogos perceber qual a distribuição
das espécies que compõem o
diversão existe outra ainda pois temos
mais o hotel foi dada ao sul era começa
com que um pequeno tutorial uma pequena
introdução em que enfim as pessoas como
elas podem detalhe seja se diz castrista
após essa introdução às pessoas somos
tratadas simples elas classificamos
precisam consultar vários sou assim
qualquer tipo de facilidade consegue
buscar quem cruel 80 a 90 por cento
tanto que qualquer profissional céu
falha diz na pichação em acção dois de
30 projetos que existem uma jogada desse
universo o universo tem média projeto
200 mil consumidores voluntários e tem
cerca de 1 milhão pois hoje no seu
global mas essas pessoas não se limitam
a ir lá e advogada objeto de lax em mais
receita elas muitas vezes ficava em
coisas novas e inesperadas poucos
momentos depois de ter sido lançado
galaxy zoo uma professora primária na
holanda chamada everton cumpriu uma no
inverno
rubian duo uma galáxia espiral chamada
em cerca de 4 97
essa nuvem verde nem sabe o que é foi de
quarta 1º uma professora primária
mostramos hoje em dia querem sair para
socar que se observe está outro exemplo
são as piriguetes ela ser filha nunca
antes vistas por mim achando por sinal
foram descobertas por perguntar fosse
para cerca de 250 não só em número 4 foi
dada pelos próprios voluntários como
hoje é usada pelos próprios
profissionais
outro exemplo para tratar se dos
planetas
o objetivo deste projeto é descobrir
planetas e pessoais para fora do nosso
sistema solar e orbita em volta de
estrelas nem sequer são mostradas
imagens do maps não é possível ter
imagens canetas mostradas
a reedição em emoção o tema é a mesma
companhia diz tanto o hábito em volta da
sua estrela a avaliação tem um drible na
pics sempre planeta passa em frente
isso é possível tentar a oim
mesmo com a gritos bastante simples mas
juntar descobriram foi um sistema com
duas estrelas para evitar uma volta da
outra
um planeta orbitando em volta dessas
duas telas e mais duas estrelas
orbitando em volta do sistema juntar
descobriram um esquema
os gritos como falharam completamente
vital pouquinho mas thrones lembrou
cigarro algoritmo que permite sustentar
as suas tão bizarra mas pensavam não
escreve observou neste e essa vantagem
dos voluntários em relação aos
algoritmos
eu sou muito melhor mas ainda há coisas
muito mais facilmente mas não só com os
favoritos muitas vezes mais os próprios
cientistas quando quando eu vou lançar o
galaxy é difícil eu não for muito mais
rapidamente alguns quilos foram muito
menos eu sofri uma maior promoção
galáxias elípticas com zonas azuis que é
precisamente aquilo quer em termos que
treinar isso não quer deixar o índice
que é o mal feito e estou simplesmente
porque é um cientista e cientista 17
natureza
muita gente conceitos porque existem
teorias e modelos nos quais trabalha há
décadas muitas vezes estão muitas vezes
em na parte descoberta científica como
como quer no chão e se me desse uma vez
um cientista tão ocupado que eu não
tenho tempo pra ser surpreendido e aqui
com os voluntários conseguem contribuir
com algo muito diferente
a grande descoberta do universo não é
aquela que fizer filha não é o planeta
suavizar a grande descoberta das amigas
são os que nós sociedade no seu pai que
consigam ser muito macho que cientistas
em várias vezes quando um problema
científico composto nas suas componentes
mais básicas
neste caso o crescimento de imagens o
coletivo funciona melhor em qualquer
circunstância estão velhos que o inverso
estréia invenção do
o processo científico vontade chegam
mais não tem votos e não terias eu tenho
muito essa jogada e mendonça contribuir
e vamos comendo com a surpresa quase por
acidente em julho do ano passado
eu tenho presente numa das reuniões de
amigos equipa dos universos com uma
equipa do ano escolar haiti metrópoles
liderada pelo senhor jorge visual com o
chamado anjo gastar os objetos não quer
em 2011 e 2010 em que estão os seus
cerca de 11km temporárias e fazia exames
básicos divisão
tanto o instante básicos como acesso foi
o hospital terá imagens na retina do
olho ao interior do olho onde prometeu
buscar imagens administrado doenças como
a malária com alzheimer diabetes e faz
muitos gols e temos com cerca de 55 mil
pessoas e eu sou a reunião ele se
mostrou fria de uma pessoa idosa com
pedradas
isso tem pessoas destas chegam à clínica
todos os dias e estar mais pra ela ela
vai ficar cega
eu preciso de ajuda eu preciso de buscar
essas pessoas com rapidez para quando
elas não cheguem às mãos e não ter tempo
para curar eu preciso da vossa ajuda e
equipes das unidades de controle quanto
às demais gestantes 7 5 mil pacientes
não querem a 5 mil pacientes têm cerca
de quatrocentas mil imagens da vítima do
fundo do olho
isto mais maria não ficou a equipa dos
pesquisados
o pessoal será levada à risca todas as
doenças quanto tempo vocês precisam
vocês universo para buscar o prazer de
ver todas as imagens em uma semana uma
semana para potencialmente como explicar
doenças e agravos dos anjos voluntários
em qualquer especialidade médica
e esta é a segunda missão dos negócios
hoje em dia não estamos cientistas
descobriu uma galáxia
não precisamos de médicos para salvar
vidas após uma vez que vai no facebook o
primeiro tempo pensei nisso